optimal like this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile for my hands
start shaking pronounce your personal
questions now it is see I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by 99designs your one-stop shop for
all things graphic design related I have
used 99 designs for everything from
banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock-ups that led to the
4-hour body which later became number
one New York Times number one Wall
Street Journal and the brainstorming a
lot of it took place with designers from
around the world and here's how it works
whether you need a t-shirt a business
card a website and app thumbnail
whatever it might be you submit that
project and designers from around the
world will send you sketches and
mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade
go to 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim that's 99designs com forward slash
Tim the Tim Ferriss show is brought to
you by on it I have used on it products
for years if you look in my kitchen in
my garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement
and you can see all of my favorite gear
at on it comm forward slash Tim that's
onn IT comm forward slash Tim and you
can also get a discount on any
supplements food products I like hemp
force I like alpha brand check it all
out on it comm forward slash Tim
guten tag my sexy little munchkins this
is Tim Ferriss in a very echo Laden
wooden room on an island and we'll be
hearing more about that in a future
episode with Chris Sacca but in the
meantime I am so excited to present an
episode that was very very physically
demanding and this conversation you are
about to listen to is with none other
than Rick Rubin and if you don't
recognize that name
well the bio could seem almost
fabricated it is so impressive so he has
been called the most important producer
that's music producer of the last 20
years by MTV and in 2007 he appeared on
x 100 most influential people in the
world list why would he appear on such a
list well if you could imagine say in
the book world that you named every
author you could think of off the top of
your head all the name brand folks and
then found out that one agent and one
editor were responsible for all of them
you'd be dumbfounded and that's pretty
much the case when you look at the
discography of Rick Rubin so he was the
former co-president of Columbia Records
he was co-founder along with Russell
Simmons of Def Jam Records and helped
popularize hip hop music by working with
the Beastie Boys LL Cool J Public Enemy
Run DMC for instance and I'm not going
to give the whole list because it's too
long but here are just some of the
artists that he has worked with Red Hot
Chili Peppers Beastie Boys which already
mentioned Johnny Cash Slayer jay-z and
he appeared in the 99 problems video
danzig Dixie Chicks Tom Petty and the
Heartbreakers Black Sabbath slipped
Metallica ac/dc Aerosmith Linkin Park
Weezer the cult Neil Diamond AHA Mick
Jagger System of a Down it goes on and
on and these genres span from say Lady
gaga to ZZ Top to Shakira and everything
in between Kanye West
Eminem you name it so he's a fascinating
guy very much a Zen monk in his
temperament and I've gotten to know Rick
over the last few years and he insisted
that we do the podcast in his sauna
which is a barrel sauna that makes your
head melt it is so intense so this was a
very challenging episode I hope you get
some laughs out of it
and I what you will realize very quickly
is you have to listen intently to Rick's
answers so Rick has sort of layers
behind layers behind layers so if I'll
tell you something and you're like wow
I'm not sure I actually get what that
means and then months later it'll dawn
on you oh my god there are so many
different depths to that answer I didn't
pick up on it the first time around so I
you will have to interpret and ponder a
lot of what Rick brings up but I hope
you enjoy this
I enjoyed it although I nearly had
heatstroke and without further ado here
is Rick Rubin well almost without
further ado folks one more adieu I
forgot to mention if you are interested
in music be sure to check out the
drumming episode of the Tim Ferriss
experiment which is my TV show it's been
the number one TV season on iTunes now
for some time amazingly but if you go to
iTunes com forward slash Tim Ferriss two
hours two S's you can see a bunch of
bonus footage all the episodes including
the drumming episode where I am trained
by Stewart Copeland the founding drummer
of the police widely considered one of
the top ten drummers of all time his
teaching method resembles doc from Back
to the Future it is an amazing
experience and I only had a few days
with the gun against my head to Train to
then play to a sold-out auditorium as
the drummer for foreigner which was a
nervous breakdown inducing to say the
least so you can check it out iTunes
comm forward slash Tim Ferriss two hours
and two S's and now here is Rick Rubin
Rick welcome to the show thanks for
having me and this setting is somewhat
unique and I've been looking forward to
it / fearing it ever since you first
mentioned to me about where are we right
now we are sitting in a sauna we're
sitting in a very hot barrel sauna and I
was told that was one of the conditions
for I think this conversation and it's
such an impressive barrel sauna it's
indoors that I wanted to get the specs
for it when I first saw it and you have
a heater that has to be about four times
the size of the off-the-shelf heater
that would go into such a heater yet
it's it's a much bigger heated and for
the size of the room right and I'm
sitting on the floor because I have such
little confidence in my ability to
withstand heat compared to you but we do
have the the alternate which is the bath
just outside of this door and you and I
have gone back and forth of course quite
a few times with this type of cycling
but what is right outside of the store a
metal tub filled with ice it is a metal
tub about four feet three and a half
feet off the ground a full of ice looks
like if you were to say what a horse
trough times - something like that
something like that it's got to be
maximum low-50s something like that I
think it's about today it's probably
about 38 degrees oh my god alright so we
have a we have two mics on the floor I'm
hoping won't explode or melt down to the
h4n and the h6 and we have water ice
heat nothing could go wrong I'm looking
forward to it so Rick I was I was hoping
perhaps we could start with a discussion
of your physical transformation and I'd
love for you to perhaps just describe to
people I mean you're in my mind the sort
of the picture of fitness in a lot of
ways now and we've been paddleboarding
before and you severely whup my ass
every time we go out I'm always pressed
there are a lot of things contributing
to my my lack of competency and fear
there but where where were you and how
did you end up undergoing this for this
physical transformation because you've
lost how much weight at this point
five thousand I lost at the peak moment
I lost between hundred and thirty five
hundred and forty pounds and I always
thought I was eating a healthy diet I
was vegan for 20-something years and all
organic vegan really you know very
strict with what I ate and doing that I
got up to 318 pounds um and I I read a
book by a guy named Stu Mittleman who
ran a thousand miles in 11 days and I
remember reading that and just thinking
wow it's like I can barely walk down the
block this camera in a thousand miles in
11 days and it just seems so inspiring
so I read his book and in the book he
talked about the die named Phil Moffitt
own who I'd never heard of before and he
said it in Stu's book he gets to the
part we said well I met this doctor film
a Fatone and he changed the way I
trained and he changed the way and he
changed all these things and then all of
a sudden I was able to do all these
things like okay I want to find filme
Fatone so I found him online I sent him
an email and he was living in Florida
and I asked if if you know I could
become his patient and he said that he
had just stopped treating patients and
retired from being a doctor it's like
let's terribleness and but the reason he
decided to stop being a doctor was he
decided to become a songwriter I said oh
it's interesting I mean funny you should
mention that have like I'm involved in
songwriting and the music world maybe we
can trade maybe I can help you with your
songwriting and you can help me with my
health and fitness and he liked the idea
and we ended up meeting a few months
later and then met several times and
became friends and then he eventually
ended up moving into my house and lived
in my house for about two years and I
did everything he said and I got much
healthier my metabolism got turned on
the hours that I was sleeping shifted I
for most of my life I'd stayed up all
night and slept most of the day and when
I was in college I never took class
before 3 p.m. because I knew I wouldn't
I wouldn't go and this is that my you at
NYU so I'm used to living a night
lifestyle even I remember even in high
school I missed I missed the first three
classes of school so many times that you
know it was really an issue but it was
just I'd learned to be up on I've
learned to be a late night person and
and it kind of suited the music life
like it worked well with my life and
when the first things that Phil
suggested when we got together was I
slept with black outlines and I usually
didn't leave the house until the Sun was
setting and he said from now on when you
wake up I want you to go outside Oh as
soon as you wake up open the blinds and
go outside naked if possible and be in
the Sun for 20 minutes and when he said
it I remember thinking he would be the
same as him saying I want you to jump
off this this ledge you know like it
sounded like the most terrifying that
based on the way I lived my life that
just sounded terrible
right um what time was he recommending
that you wake up well he by the time we
started it kept moving down and in it um
they went from 3 o'clock - probably noon
to 11:00 to 9:00 and it just sort of
happened naturally and he knew that if I
immediately went in the Sun that
naturally my body would want to start
waking up earlier and going to sleep
earlier it was the first time ever that
my circadian rhythm was kicking in it
never was I never knew that there was
such a thing or knew what that was so he
he got me to connect to that and I did
everything he said changed my diet
started eating some animal protein I was
as I said a devout vegan so eggs and
were the first things that I would eat
and even then I never liked eggs and I
never liked fish so I ate them more like
medicine and slowly I got healthier and
healthier and healthier and more and
more thin but I was still very heavy and
I was heavy for a long time what age
were you when you brought him into your
house or how long ago is this yeah I'm
gonna guess I'm gonna guess was probably
late 30s and how if you don't mind me
asking yeah ten years ago ten twelve
years ago something like that so you
were changing your dad where were some
of the other things that he had you
change that he had me do 20 minutes of
low heart rate exercise aerobic activity
every day and he had me start wearing a
heart rate monitor and my heart rate I
would get into you know for me walking
up a flight of stairs would be an
aerobic activity so I had to really
watch what I was doing to to stay or I
had a road bike activity yeah so I had
to work hard to stay in the anaerobic
space or the aerobic specimen in the
aerobic space below that to get an audio
yetis kick on here I would take off all
your clothes my hands my hands burn and
culturing the bike I tried to wrap him
in napkins I'm heat it didn't mention
those might get hot but sorry I digress
so to stay within the aerobic threshold
you had yes work very hard yes and again
my health changed but I still stayed
very heavy and after two years of time I
probably had probably lost a little bit
of weight but not much but I was much
healthier and much more alive and much
better than I was before and after that
period of time Phil said to me you know
anyone else who made the changes you
made
out of everyone he's ever dealt with 99%
out of a hundred people you know 99 out
of 100 people would have dropped all
their weight for some reason there's
something else going on with you that's
holding on to the weight so and so I
just accepted that that's how it was but
at least I felt I felt a lot better my
life was a lot better I was a lot
happier and then I'm a mentor of mine
whose name's mo Ostin he's a guy who ran
Warner Brothers Records for 35 years he
worked for Frank Sinatra real inspiring
guy in music business he suggested I
went out to lunch with him one day and
he said you know Rick I'm really worried
about you I know you watch what you eat
and I know that you you know walk on the
beach every day and exercise but you're
really getting big and I'm worried so he
said I'm gonna get the name of a
nutritionist and I want you to go to my
guy and I want you to do whatever he
says I said okay fine look I and I knew
it wouldn't work because I knew that my
whole life I had a weight problem my
whole life I've tried every diet and
nothing ever worked
and but I you know I would do anything
for Moe so I went again open-minded but
not believing it would work willing to
try but not believing it would work and
the nutritionist put me on a
high-protein low-calorie diet and I'd
never done a low-calorie diet before and
over 14 months I lost 130 pounds 135
pounds yeah and it changed that changed
everything and I I will say if I didn't
do the work with Phil first I don't
believe that the diet would worked it
was sort of a combination of things in
order was like the metabolism got turned
on I started being in tune in circadian
rhythm I was stimulating my aerobic
system every day
and was I built a base and then with the
right diet was able to drop the way
quickly well what's what's so
interesting about that and I have a
couple of more questions about what the
nutritionist prescribed but is that in
my experience with say tens of thousands
of readers following various diets
including this low-carb diet it makes
perfect sense because you were you were
adding things in in the beginning as
opposed to having everything prohibited
you're adding elements in and then once
you've added those lifestyle components
at that point you were able to to change
the the diet and then experience the wow
that is hot yeah I was gonna say even
with even with Phil though I changed my
diet
it just was you know like almond butter
was something that I was allowed to eat
because in Phil's world almond butter is
healthy right so I probably ate a third
of a jar of almond butter ever exactly
that's my issue with things like almond
butter yeah who's Joe Domino food
exactly so so the idea of Phil has a
belief and so many people have a belief
that calories don't count and I
understand that but if you eat 10,000
calories a day right you're probably
going to gain weight you're not going to
lose weight so it's like there is a
point absolutely R calories do make a
difference oh for sure yeah I mean there
are there cases where it's if it's a
question of between 4500 and 5000
calories like okay yeah suburban
calories sugar calories and fat calories
very different but fifteen ten thousand
calories of all and put it before you go
to bed yeah which I will do if I have
almond butter my house yeah and best not
to have in my house
with the when you lost the hundred and
thirty hundred forty pounds over that
period of time how many of your mules
how many meals are you eating per day
and how many of them were whole food
versus liquid to lose the weight I was
having seven protein shakes a day that
were um high-protein things they were
like egg protein j-rod protein was one
of them Tara's way whey protein was
another and did you alternate those or
combine them no at first I did only egg
mmm that the way came later and
first I couldn't tolerate the way for
some reason that the way made me
uncomfortable once I lost a bunch of
weight I could eat the way so egg was
first that makes that also makes sense I
mean having any amount of lactose or
dairy reintroduced after being vegan sir
for such a long period of time you know
a lot of people have noticed who say try
to reintroduce animal proteins feel sick
but it's because they they lack the
enzymes at that point after say ten
years I'm not consuming meat to digest
it properly
ah do you want to do a nice round or do
you want me to do a nice hand cuz I feel
like I'm getting close
yeah I'd say why don't uh why don't you
do a nice round and then I'll do a nice
round because we're at higher elevation
I'm sitting on the floor for those
people who can't see oh yes no joke oh
god to hundreds not even 200 it's about
a hundred and ninety
holy crap 195 degrees in here alright so
220 oh good lord 220 that's uh yeah
that's a well-done steak right there
it's very well done
alright I will hang out in here now see
out there in a minute
I'm holding both mics now sitting on the
floor two containers water and I have a
Russian spa hat on they make you look
somewhat like the Keebler elves and mine
has a lion on it
and I have to only guess the Cyrillic
says spot line which is appropriate
because I think of myself as spotlight
on a related note folks if I do dive
heatstroke in here it's been lovely
knowing you and I'm going to press stop
now to save my breath for the ice round
we'll be back and we're back refreshed
after some where we're getting colder
adding ice but it was at about 44
degrees Fahrenheit so Rick you'd
mentioned this this gent or doctor or
lady from UCLA who was at the doctor at
UCLA who helped me lose the weights name
was dr. Heber G BER and he really
he's of everything I tried nothing ever
worked until dr. Huber and do you still
follow the the general diet or have you
been able to after losing that weigh it
modify that I've modified it in that I
still eat a lot of protein and don't
have any grain
yeah really not no carbs and keep while
I probably don't restrict calories as
much as I did in the weight loss phase
I'm aware of it I'm aware of them and
don't let them get out of control you've
developed a sensitivity the unawareness
and for a period of time I used an app
um I think it was called Fitness Pal if
I can remember correctly where you put
in all the food that you eat and it
tells you the calories and just kind of
keep a log and what was just helpful
about it is if you pay attention to
calories for let's say a year you then
really have a sense of where the
calories are hidden and you just have
better habits oh absolutely
just like if you're trying to get into
say ketosis and we're following
something like that constant for
instance you develop a sensitivity to
hidden sugars absolutely and sort of net
carbohydrate so I'd love to to shift
gears a little bit and ask you about
music producing let's let's perhaps take
even a step back and and ask when when
people ask you what you do how do you
answer that question I don't know how to
answer that question you don't have to
answer though so would what does a let's
perhaps start with definitions and what
is a music producer do for those people
not familiar but I don't know what I
don't know what music producers do I can
tell you I can tell you what I do
ok let's do that uh which is I help get
the best performance from an artist help
help
pick their material or develop their
material and help set the course for the
direction of what they're doing
creatively and how did you end up
initially becoming involved with that
type of work um
I don't know how you usually do and I
guess you can do it in many different
ways
some people might start as a recording
engineer and then graduate to a record
producer
some people might be successful artists
and then transition into being record
producers in my case I was just really a
fan of music and I come at it from the
point of view of being a fan what did
you study at NYU I started as a
philosophy major and then after two
years I switched to film and television
because all my friends are in film and
television and it just seemed like more
fun was it more fun it was
I think it's Natalie Manor the the Dixie
Chicks yeah it said and this is
paraphrasing but that you let music be
discovered not manufactured and this
this what does she mean by that or what
do you think she means by that well we
have a whole process to pick you know
it's different for every artist but we
we try to go on a journey and let the
artist discover who they are and in the
process the best art comes from them
it's like getting to be their true
selves and trying to take away all of
the there's so many things that get in
the way of the artistic process for
example any commercial considerations
usually get in the way if you're
thinking about making music that's going
to get on the radio chances are you
won't be using your your own voice to
its
most potent most singular um you know
finding the what your personal gift is
so that's one of it that's one of many
things just it's getting closer to the
source and not being distracted by any
uh any nonsense that would get in the
way of the art being as good as it could
be what are other things that get in the
way of artists producing their best work
mmm concerned about what other people
think competition wanting to do better
than someone else um see what are the
things self-doubt um ego what
manifestation of you go um
if someone thinks that everything they
do is great they might not be willing to
edit themselves enough or work hard
enough at you know if I can write if I
could write ten great songs in five
minutes each and those are the best
songs and I'm just going to record it
and put them out and those might not be
as good as the ones that you develop
over a lot of period of time for example
that might be an egotistical Odyssey
things everything I do is just great
when you have the opposite when you have
an artist who is doubting themselves how
do you help them through that um or what
is uh what do you recommend I have a lot
I mean I just speaking personally I have
continuous self-doubt as a writer I
think most I think most artists do
that's more the more typically
self-doubt is the case I think if your
goal is to be better than you were you
know if you're competing only with
yourself
it's a more realistic it's a more
realistic place to be you know if you
say I don't want to write songs unless I
can write songs better than the Beatles
it's a hard road but if you say I want
to write a better song tomorrow than the
song I wrote yesterday that's a
realistic that's something that can be
done and if you write a better song than
you wrote yesterday every day then you
continue to get better and better and
better and it really is small steps and
and also trying not to try not to think
too much because so much of it is more
of a the job is it's more emotion and
hard work than it is head work like that
the head comes in after to look at what
the heart has presented and to organize
it but the initial inspiration comes
from a different place and it's not the
head and it's not an intellectual
activity it's a it's more of a it's more
inspiration so the key first is to
really do whatever activities you can to
tune in to inspiration and things like
meditating help and diving into art in
general doesn't have to be even your
modality I mean go into museums looking
at beautiful art can help you write
better songs reading great novels
reading great great works of art um
seeing a great movie could inspire a
great song
reading poetry so I would say being in
submerging yourself in great art and the
more you can do to get out of the mode
of competition where you're looking at
what other people are doing and wanting
to be better than them or be inspired by
them
say the only the only way to use the
inspiration of other artists is if you
submerge yourself in the greatest works
of all time which is a great thing to do
you know like if you listen to the
greatest music ever made that would be a
better a better way to work through to
find your own voice to matter today then
listening to what's on the radio now and
thinking I want it you know compete with
this right it's more like a stepping
back and looking at a bigger picture
then what's going on at the moment it's
someone speaking as someone who is not
very well versed with music I don't feel
highly literate when it comes to music I
enjoy music but hanging out with with
you and Neil Strauss certainly I feel
like I'm lacking perhaps a vocabulary
too and a lot of references are there
any for people who feel like they're in
my shoes are there any particular albums
that you would you could offer as a
starting point not the end-all be-all
but just as a as a starting point for
appreciating good world-class
contemporary music meaning not
necessarily could be classical music but
are there any recommendations I would
just start by listening to the Great's
which you can look at like if you look
at search online for Mojo's top 100
albums of all time or Rolling Stones top
100 albums or any trusted sources top
100 albums and start listening to what
you know whatever what are considered
the greats it's a good place to start
and are there any particular stories
that you have that come to mind of
experiences outside of the medium of
music saying a specific film or a
specific trip or a specific book that
catalyzed a breakthrough in the work
that you did you think about that for
sick
yeah I wouldn't say breakthrough um
because it's a more it's a more personal
thing than NASA doesn't come as much
from the outside but I get inspiration
every day you know every day from either
what I'm reading or watching a sunset or
the you know the world noticing the
amount of birds that fly overhead what
they look like in their different shapes
and paying attention or hearing the
sound of the waves all of those things
speak to your looking at the horizon um
they all speak to me and so much of the
work we try to do is to create something
with the natural balance that we see in
nature that that's sort of the perfect
version of you know if you can make a
piece of music that can take your breath
away as much as a beautiful sunset
you've done well so um you know any
opportunity to see dolphins swim or see
you know see something beautiful that's
not your run-of-the-mill experience or
even could be a beautiful cloud filled
sky um we're you know on a particularly
clear night when you can really see lots
of stars those are they're all inspiring
things and um help turn on the muse of
recognizing um kind of a greater vision
of either what's possible oh it's
beautiful
then you know something that you see in
a magazine that's you know advertisement
that there to entice you to buy it
all right and it was can you talk a
little bit about the when you realized
that you were good at working with
musicians or music when did that happen
yeah when did that happen and are there
any particular whether it's instances or
artists or you're like wow I think I
might actually have a knack for this
well I start
right from the beginning I started
having a lot of success in it and it I
did it I really made music as a hobby
while I was in college and thought I
would have a real job and then I would
make music as my hobby and I thought I
would have a job to support my music
habit and then the first album I
produced was by LL Cool J he was 16 at
the time and I think it cost us about
$8,000 to record and sold 900,000 copies
and that was a good start that is good
man the second one was Beastie Boys
which I think sold I don't know 9 or 10
million and from then on like just a lot
of record sold a lot right from the
beginning so it it took a long time for
me to understand that that doesn't
always happen you know he's an unusual
series of events but after a long time
of having a lot working with a lot of
artists and seeing a lot of success it
it became clear that um I could support
artists and doing good work and people
seem to appreciate it
what are what are the some of the ways
that what are some of the things or
characteristics that make you perhaps
different from other people who work
with musicians it's hard to know that I
don't know so what other people do but I
I don't think we do the same thing and I
think there are some producers who make
beats for artists and there was a time
that I did that early in early in my
career I did that still on occasion will
do it if you know if it if it makes
sense with the the project that I'm
doing I think it's unusual that I get to
work in lots of different genres and get
to make heavy metal records and rap
records and country records and
spiritual records all do all different
kinds
so I think that's unusual and just lucky
and I think that might come from the
fact that I come from it from that fan
perspective and I like all kinds of
music and I get to examine them and and
the fact that I've been able to work on
so many different kinds of music over
such a long period of time gives me a
good perspective because when I come
into a new project it's not it's it's
rare that I'm going to the studio to
work on another of what I was just
working on so let's say for example I
was a heavy metal producer and all I did
for the last thirty years was produce
heavy metal I don't know how fresh those
records would be today but now if I get
to produce a heavy metal record like the
last one I did I guess would be the last
Black Sabbath album it was really fun
cuz I hadn't made a record like that in
a long time and and it was a brand new
experience and I was at 13-13 this last
one yet and um that was a great
experience really fun never worked with
those guys before and we had a great
time so I'm not sure I ever told you the
first time I ever saw the name Rick
Rubin was actually on the inside of a an
audio cassette it was the first heavy
metal album I ever bought which was
rainin blue it's a good one and I just
remember that's a really good not having
is the pre-internet of course and I I
was just told by my friends you have to
you will love heavy metal you should
listen heavy metal and I asked what the
hardest heavy metal was that could
possibly be found and rain and blood
came to the lips of those I asked and
and I just remember listening to you I
think it's angel of death the first
track on that and going oh my god what
have I gotten myself into and just fell
in love with the band but how did you go
from hip-hop to say Slayer it's a
stylistically so different in a scene
but how did Slayer come about yeah as I
said it because I was coming about it
with no technical skill it's not like I
knew about hip-hop or I knew about heavy
metal I was a fan of music and I loved
heavy metal I loved hip-hop so it was
more that coming at it from this
appreciation and as a fan knowing what I
wanted to hear knowing that
you know especially in the case of
Slayer Slayer were an underground metal
band who had two albums out on an
independent label and we're kind of
considered you know the heaviest band in
the world and when we signed them there
was this terrible fear that Slayer now
doing their first album for a major
label it was gonna you know they were
going to sell out get water done yeah
and which happens all the time and then
the album that we made rain and blood
was much harder and worse than anything
that I've ever heard before and um and
it really did come from that you know I
liked I always liked extreme things and
they were extreme and I wanted to
maximize it I didn't want to water down
you know the I do it
the idea of watering things down for a
mainstream audience it I don't think it
applies I think people want things that
are really passionate and the best
version of that they could be and often
the best version they could be is not
for everybody right best the best art
divides the audience where you you know
if you put out a record and half the
people who hear it absolutely love it
and half the people who here absolutely
hate it
you've done well because it's pushing
that that boundary if everyone thinks ah
that's pretty good why bother making it
you know it's sort of doesn't it doesn't
mean much lost in the slipstream of time
almost as soon as it comes out I'm gonna
do a round of ice if that's all right
absolutely all right let's do some more
ice and we'll be back okay we are we are
back and I'd love to talk a little bit
about say for instance LL Cool J vs.
Slayer is the way in which you work with
those two groups of creatives or in the
case of LL Cool J I don't know how many
people were involved on his side but is
a is there a different approach when
giving feedback when trying to cultivate
other lady it's really different with
every single artist and it's um you
spend time with the artist you get to
know them and if you if you listen to
people if you really listen to what
people say
usually they they tell you everything if
you really listen pay attention to what
people are saying they'll let you know a
lot of stuff and I just really pay
attention what people say and through
that I can then reflect back um thoughts
that they've told me about themselves
that they don't know about themselves
and allow them to unlock those doors to
to get to the places they want to go
artistically are there any particular
examples of that where our story that
you could sure mister the first story
that comes to mind isn't related to my
music work but it's related to our
friend Neil and just the journey the
journey that led to his new book that
that's about to come out started through
him complaining about something going on
in his life that uh he thought was
something that he wanted in his life and
I don't think that he knew that thing
that he wanted was making him unhappy
and through that conversation he decided
to examine that so that be an example
didn't say same thing is that that first
one way in mind maybe because we both
know Neil write the you seem very
obviously philosophical philosophically
minded very calm and I should thank you
also you and the friend named Chase
Jarvis actually he's a world-class
photographer the people who got me into
meditation consistently with TM hey so
thank you for that but have you always
been very calm and I mean doesn't you
seem very unperturbed
be unfazed by by anything that I've
observed it has that is that is is that
an illusion is or have you always been
that way um I'm very lucky and then I
learned to meditate when I was young so
I started meditating when I was 14 and I
meditated a lot for a long time and
through that I think it has really even
even though I'm not always calm on the
inside it has at least given me an air
of calm and maybe a comparative to other
people out and probably come
I know sometimes internally I can get
disrupted what do you do when you get
disrupted I try to do something like
often exercise will make me feel better
meditating will make me feel better ice
bath is the greatest of all King element
elevators it's just the magic someone
ice back and forth at the end of at the
end of the fourth or fifth or sixth
round of being in an ice tub there is
nothing in the world that bothers you
that's true it's very true like the
world's great place what do what are the
types of things that uh disrupt you
there any particular patterns hmm I
would say usually work things or
political related you know political
type things related to work could really
bother me just um they don't fit into my
into my realm of the way I look at life
so I get surprised by those things and
just having to manage say the various
relationships on the within a label or
something like that
yeah I would say more like dealing with
business people Birkin can often like
wow you really think that you're the one
do things that way that's surprising it
had you how have you designed what are
some of the ways in which you've
designed your life to say not have to
contend with as much of that as possible
well I always um really try to focus my
life around art so I consider my job
even though there are other parts of my
job I consider my real job the reason
I'm here is to sit with artists talk to
artists help artists be better at what
they do
um and if I'm not doing it with an
artist I'm doing it with something else
like my goal is to make things as good
as they could be either make whatever it
is that means I'm to the point to where
I've gone into friend visit friends in
their office and I rearrange the
furniture and they are in our office
because I'm insane you know it would
really look better you know if you move
these things this way and you can see
the sudden coming in through the window
here and if you open these blinds and
turn this around this place would feel
much more comfortable when you think of
the word successful who is the first
person who comes to mind it's not it's
not such an easy question to answer
because I mean so many things go into
what makes someone successful what are
some of those things I would start with
have somebody who's happy you know I
know a great many people who are
financially successful and not happy so
I would rule all them out start with C
it's not coming so easily I have to
think about that we'll come back we can
come back to it how do you this is a big
question but I'll ask a very
self-interested question so I'm 37 of
course we both spent a lot of time
around Neal and okay I'm not going to
spoil the secret because Neal would have
going to apoplectic shock but the next
book I'm looking forward to I just
thought of who a couple of ated ampuls
of people who were successful let's do
it a good example of someone who's
successful is Don Wildmon our friend
from the beach
twice whom I still have not met yet okay
he's amazing like he's 80 years old
she's um did 23 pull-ups on the beach
the other day she's uh in the Senior
Olympics he retired in his 50s because
he wanted to spend his days enjoying
life and exercising and he's one of the
most inspiring uplifting great
successful people on so many levels
on so many levels he'd be he'd be
probably the first one I think of
Laird's another great example of someone
who I would think of as successful he's
a successful human being and his Laird
Hamilton Laird Hamilton for those people
who are not familiar with with Laird
pretty much I'd say it uncontroversially
thought of as the king of big wave
surfing among among other things yeah I
mean it's not uncommon to hear him
referred to as the greatest athlete on
earth he's real you know so many
athletes of so many disciplines think of
him as the best athlete also a king of
steam rooms and I spats I first started
doing this on ahem high zoom there
anyway successful someone who enjoys
their life is great at what they do is
curious and continually pushing forward
and wanting to be better than they were
yesterday without a
without beating themselves up about it
and what hurts that the don don is isn't
his name has come up so many times what
are some of the things that you've
learned or picked up from him and adopt
for yourself he's just seemed so
positive and so if nothing it seems like
nothing gets to him he's um he couldn't
he can push through anything that's in
his way and all the time with a smile on
his face
and a positive outlook and uh and a
curious nature you know how I don't know
how many people that are 80 that every
time you meet them talk tele to you know
teach you something about something new
they've learned because they're so
curious about a great article or this
great book and you have to read this
book then you have to go to see this
movie and you have to do this and um you
know we just came back from snowboarding
in Alaska and you got to go see you like
we was unbelievable and just it's he's
got a wild life that's inspiring I've in
the last I'd say three or four years
particularly after my my health scare
last year with Lyme disease and
everything that came of that tried to
surround myself not just with the
extremely young athletes and performers
but for instance this polish gentleman
and his wife both of whom are world
record holders and Olympic weightlifting
but what's what's so fascinating is how
well a relatively injury-free and mobile
they still are and they're in there I'd
say early 60s at this point made and
I've tried to really try to spend more
time last few years modeling what those
people do do you have a book or books
that you've gifted often to other people
um they're there many the first one that
comes to mind
is the daodejing it's this Steven
Mitchell translation of the daodejing
that's what's great about it is it's 81
short pieces that could be could look at
them his poems that if you were to read
the book today you would get one thing
from it and if you pick it up in the two
years and read it again it would mean
something entirely different
and and always on the money you know
always what you need to read at that
period of time so it's it's a magic book
in that way that it it always fits
I actually took how this is bringing
back a memory I took a cut an entire
class on the daodejing at Princeton when
I was an undergrad in East Asian Studies
and it seems on some level that that
book does what you do for musicians
meaning it sort of reflects back truths
that they were not aware of themselves
or they could not verbalize themselves
any other books come to mind another one
that's really nice is book about
meditation called wherever you go there
you are which is by Jon kabat-zinn
that's a great it's a great book if
you've never meditated and if you've
been meditating for 50 years if you read
if you read this book either way you
will care more about meditation become a
better meditator and just give insight
into why we do it and what the benefits
are give any favorite any favorite
movies or documentaries oh and watch
lots of documentaries let me think
what's what's a favorite just watch one
the other night that was spectacular new
Nick Cave the English well I guess he's
Australian lives in England musician has
a there's a new documentary that's an
unusual documentary because it's part
documentary in part I guess not you have
to see it but it's called 20,000 days on
earth
20,000 days on earth yeah so that was
the last one it just really like wow how
great is that are there any points uh
have you had any points of overwhelm in
your length in your in your length in
your that's an odd question I think the
Heat's getting to my head in your in
your Creed's getting to the Heat's
getting to me I just watch my hand is
burning okay do you experience overwhelm
or have you yes I definitely experience
overwhelm yeah Oh too much going on at
one at one time or often it's it's
self-imposed I I make it a point to
always be there as best as I can be for
the artists that I work with and
sometimes their needs can overtake my
own needs and then I feel overwhelmed
because I want to be there for them and
then I feel like oh I'm not taking care
of myself so finding that balance what
do you what do you do in those
situations when you when you come to
that realization when I realize that
I'll usually talk to the artist about it
and and then explain the situation
do you know look for three I would say
any situation that feels sticky usually
through talking about it with the person
that feels sticky with almost always it
eases very quickly and usually brings
you closer together and do you explain
the situation the way that you just
described it to me or its what it what
is the actual it just depends on it on
the case but it but I might say you know
I feel really overwhelmed now this is
what's going on with me can we talk
about this later
you know can we address this is that
okay I usually talk about it hey feeling
good uh you tell me yeah I'll let you
call the call the the rotation of the
guards when we go to ice but Diane I'm
very curious
I remember seeing or you have myself I
think this is a fine idea I will say I
will absolve myself a responsibility for
hot objects but the your cameo in 99
problems yes how did that come about
I had produce a song for J and then when
it was time to make the video a friend
of mine mark romantic was a great video
maker made the video and I think it was
Mark's idea she said why don't we get
Rick in the video and Jay agreed and
then they call Nestor I would come and I
love Jay he's a really great guy and I
thought it would be fun I what uh what
are you proudest of as it relates to
that track um if it comes to mind I know
you have not a lot of tracks yeah I
think that uh just the fact that Jay is
one of the most you know important
artists in the world and that that's one
of his most popular songs and that we
have to do together is really great how
are you how did you become involved with
that song or were you involved with the
entire album um I was involved with that
song we went into the studio together he
it was his last it was going to be his
last album black out on his retirement
album and he asked his 10 favorite
producers to each do one song and we
went into the studio that was the first
time we worked together and we who spent
a week in the studio trying different
things and then eventually came on this
track and in the experimentation and he
loved it then the words came to him sort
of magically he sat in the back of the
room listen
track over and over over again and after
about a half-hour jumped up and set up
got it and ran into the other room and
then vocals I'm not writing anything
down so I've heard this about him before
where at some point I heard a story that
he wrote basically gibberish down on a
piece of paper because someone trying to
supervise him earlier in his career was
so worried that he wasn't taking the
recording session seriously but in fact
he didn't write anything down at all was
just to put them at ease yeah and then
freestyle the entire thing is that
generally how he operates that's how he
does it yeah that's exciting
mind-boggling
yeah he's super talented and just a
great great person really one of my
favorite people what do you like about
him everything he's humble he's honest
he's uh he's a deep soul you know he
looks at things deeply understands them
deeply is caring and it's just a you
know first great person I think I'm
gonna get in the house all right I'm
doing to the ice my paws up yeah yeah I
was right this is Reza
yeah heads up it does that up that was a
particularly chilly ice bath it's now
lower than the minimum measurement which
is 40 degrees so I feel like all my skin
below my neck is just contracted by 30%
it's a good feeling and you'd mention
this briefly when we were coming in but
who is who is the person who introduced
you to using a sauna
yeah the first sauna that I was ever in
was a local friend of ours Chris Chelios
who's a hockey player and he was the hit
the longest hockey professional hockey
career of anyone ever he continued
playing professionally until he was 48
years old and all the people on the
other teams that he was facing at the
time
20s so he's really an unbelievable
athlete and he um has done sauna every
day of his life for the last you know
since he's been playing and he could he
believes the reason he had the longevity
in the sport and the reason he never got
sick and was able to never miss a game
and to play for you know such a long
career was all due to the sauna every
day and he used uh hot sauna he was not
alternating between hot and cold he did
hot and cold but he wouldn't necessarily
always use an ice bath he would do cold
showers if not uh but he would do 15 or
20 minutes in the sauna cold shower 15
or 20 minutes in the sauna round and
round and how were you introduced to the
ice baths of ice baths came from Joakim
Noah who's um my girlfriend's nephew and
he um he bought an ice tub for Laird
because he's Laird started doing the
sauna after after Chris started the
sauna ah where our group we would do it
on the beach Chris has a sauna on the
beach who do the sauna and even in the
wintertime then jump into the ocean and
that was how he did the hot Nicole and
then Joakim suggested we started using
the ice tub um and then we started doing
that that was took it to a whole new
level and you've done some very unusual
training that sounds terrifying to me
underwater right a Dan yard do you
continue to do the underwater training
with weights yeah that's something that
we do with Laird we'll do like 50 pound
dumbbells 14 feet underwater and it's
it's an interesting experience a lot
like getting into the ice bath like if
you're not used to getting into an ice
bath most people if you say get into a
tub of ice they react negatively at
panic or not they panic and when you're
underwater holding weights your brain
goes crazy and it you know relates to oh
it's like weight under water
died that's like cement shoes right and
so we do all these different exercise
weights underwater and it's really
interest and do you what these unders
and keep in mind folks do this don't do
this without supervision
talk to your doctor but the what what is
the technique look like a real example
hearted it started Laird has a pool that
you can start in the shallow end and
walk down to the deep end and then up
the center of the pool there's a
staircase in underwater so it started
with holding heavy weights walking from
the shallow end into the deep end and
obviously there's a point we have to
take a big breath and hold it and then
you walk down into the deep end and then
you turn around and you walk up the
stairs and make it before you run out of
breath and each time you do it you would
make wider and wider circles and get
used to being under longer and longer
and then we started adding once we were
completely submerged start adding maybe
curls or shoulder presses and doing
those underwater and then one day after
we've been doing this for about a year
Laird came into the gym the next day and
he said I had a dream last night that if
we use lighter weights
they'll be heavy enough to keep us down
but light enough where we could get up
where we could jump up to the top in the
deep end in the deep end so you'd be
down in the deep end so now instead of
doing one rep and recovering which was
all we could do before you need to do
one round basically and then be the
shallow end didn't recover we started
doing these exercise of jumping so we'd
start with maybe fifteen pound dumbbells
and you would hold to 15 pound dumbbells
jump into the deep end sink to the
bottom
um and jump as hard as you can throw
your arms over your
head and then kind of do one stroke
pulling your arms down to your sides
while holding the dumbbells and it was
just enough to get your head out and you
gasp for a breath and then you'd sink
and we do that over and over and over
again and you know that first maybe the
goal would be to try to get ten in a row
and I'd be really a big deal and we can
do ten in a row and then you know over
time we worked up to being able to do
100 in a row and then doing it with
heavier weights and then since then
let's come up with maybe I don't know 50
different exercises that we do with
weights under water either under water
or in water and Wow he dreams up some
really fascinating not only exercises
but devices at those people haven't seen
the foil board is that what it is with
the oil boards amaze the foil board yes
people can beautiful wound up paddling
really you know he invented stand-up
paddling he invented tow-in surfing um
he's an amazing he's got an amazing um
analytical mind do you think did he
develop that in a particular way the
mind the analytical mind is I think he's
uh Shh I think he's very mechanical to
start with Fink starts with that and um
very curious and very hard-working
and he was willing to try things and and
fail at things to be able to get to you
know to be able to do something so he
you know the first day I went to his gym
I couldn't do one pushup and really it
was through his uh his belief in his
inspiration that I was able to learn all
the different things that I was able to
learn with him and I remember he showed
me one exercise I couldn't do it at all
and I said I can't do that and he said
no don't say you can't do it say you
haven't done it yet and then he'd say
okay now let's divide it into three
pieces do the first third of the
exercise and I could do the first third
and I do the last third of the exercise
and I can do that
and I do the middle third by itself and
I can do that he's a peanut but the
first two pieces together and I could do
that and then put the second and third
piece together and I could do that and
eventually I could do the whole exercise
but at first it seemed impossible but he
walked me through it and broke it down
for him yeah just taught me how to see
past the limitations that I put on
myself what was the exercise how do you
recall what that ones that might have
been a like a jump through like whoo it
would be like a like a burpee with
weights where you would let you do a
shoulder press and hold them hold the
dumbbells jump back into a push-up
position then jump up and slide your
legs forward through right right and
then jump up into a squat position and
then lift up and that would be one one
round that's an intense movement what
are some of the the physical experiments
that you're doing these days um or
training protocols that you're
experimenting with there's always so
many I think what's what's new in that
I've been doing hyperbaric oxygen and I
really like that that's in a chamber
yeah I do the wim HOF breathing
technique I just started doing there's a
wim HOF 10-week course you could check
online wim HOF just started learning
that he's a fascinating guy yeah he's
really entice you can see yeah I've
never seen anyone more tolerant of ice I
think he has the world record for
sitting in a box
biscuit cube of ice and I think the knee
climb Mount Everest just didn't swim
he had some incredible thermo regulatory
capabilities they has very impressive me
he ran a marathon in the UM in the
desert with no water that was another
one he thought I'm just is two extremes
of the heat or the cold the guy's a
monster yeah I really want to get him on
the podcast at some point you'd be a
good one
let's pseudos those are the ones that
come to mind at the moment what uh how
do you just as layer did for you when
you are working with an artist who
believes they can't do something or it's
just hitting that wall what are some of
the ways that you help them get past
that um usually I'll give them um Macomb
work like a small doable task give you
an example there's an artist at work
even recently who was who hadn't made
mountain in a long time and was
struggling with struggling with
finishing anything and and just had this
mecca it was a version of a writer's
block but it was a I don't know hard to
explain what it was but I would give him
very doable homework assignments that
almost seemed like a joke you know like
tonight I want you to write one word you
know one word in this song that needs
five lines they can't finish I just want
one word that he like but tomorrow do
you think you come up with one word and
usually be like I can do one word and
then just be very quickly by chip by
breaking it down into pieces like I
learned from Laird and chipping away um
one step at a time you can you can
really get through anything
yeah breaking it down into an answer by
it's a beach we had a yup zip line ain't
nothing as a blinding um you know the
the beam a balance on Oh a slackline
slap on
and Laird was pretty good at it in the
beginning but had never done it before
and he would work for hours he would
just be there
hour after hour after hour falling off
and getting back on falling off getting
back on and then of all of the group of
people he was by far the first one who
was able to do it and it wasn't because
he just naturally was gifted at it he's
he knows that anything he sets his mind
to learn to do if he focuses and just
continues to you know not mind falling
off and not thinking he's supposed to be
good out-of-the-box learning to be able
to do it that's how you learn things so
I also will say that after having the
weight problem that I had for so long
and then finally finding the solution
and making the change it really makes me
believe that anything's possible
you know we can learn we can train
ourselves to do absolutely anything it's
really just getting the right
information if we get get the right
information we can learn to do anything
whatever it is now it doesn't be we can
necessarily be the best in the world at
something but we can be our best at that
thing right the best version of
ourselves yeah and do things that never
dreamed of as possibly not possible for
us what what advice would you give and
I'll ask this for a couple of different
ages but I'll start with your 20 year
old self what advice would you give your
20 year old self if any try to have more
fun
why do you think you weren't having as
much fun as you could have at that point
mm I think I was more driven and um I
don't know one say almost like I felt I
had something to prove I don't know I
did have something improved but it felt
like I felt like doing the work was the
most important thing in the world as
opposed to doing the work and enjoying
the process and you know feeling what it
was being able to step back and see what
it was you know not just be so deeply
into it that you know I feel like I
missed a lot of years of my life because
I was just in darkroom working on music
you know seven days a week for only 20
years Wow I recall that makes me think
of a story from Neil Gaiman the writer
when he I think it was with the success
of Sandman and he was in a huge line of
readers who wanted signatures and fans
who wanted to tell him stories and
Stephen King pulled him aside and just
said enjoy it and he didn't he didn't he
was too caught up in the in the flow
what about your 30 year old self what
advice would you give to your 30 year
old self
I guess I'm probably telling myself
something that I bet still might apply
to me today um I wouldn't know that at
all but I know it now I just still it's
not second nature but um to be kinder to
myself cuz I beat myself up a lot and
because I expect a lot from myself I'll
be hard on myself I don't know what I'm
doing anyone and he said
yeah that's advice that I need to give
myself as well when do you tend to beat
yourself up hmm I've made somewhat of a
sport of it it would seem yeah it can
happen you know anytime I can come up
with anything that I could be doing
further something and didn't already
think of it and didn't already do it I
might beat myself up about why you know
why I had not done that now something
something I struggle with that I'd love
to get your two cents on at is related
to this which is on one hand I don't
want to beat myself up on the other hand
I feel like the perfectionism that I
have has enabled me to do it's achieve
whatever modicum of success I've been
able to achieve and I've heard stories
and you can correct me if I'm wrong but
about for instance ZZ Top and la fruta
and you know how they worked on it with
you from I guess I want to say what 2008
to 2012 something like that but how they
realized the value of you wanting the
art to be as perfect as it could be or
the best that it could be and taking
whatever time and pains necessary to
make that possible so I'd love to hear
your thoughts on that because it's
something that I continually struggle
with and want to be easier on myself but
I worry that if I do that I will lose
whatever magic if there is such a thing
that enables me to do what I do I think
that ultimately the I think that's a
myth
and I think that your take on things is
specific to you and it's not because of
you or you it's it's almost like you've
won the war and to accept the fact that
you've won the war you have broken
through to now you have an audience
people are open to hear hear what you
are interested in what you learn at what
you're interested in learning about and
what you want to share
and you can you can do that without
killing yourself
and that killing yourself won't be of
service either to you or to your
audience guys all right you know what
let's let's it this is this has been
great I need ice as well let's let's
call a close to this is there any last
parting advice or comment that you'd
like to make before we sign off I think
it's it's too hot for me to know what's
even I don't know what's happening
what's up or down yeah
very confused and whelming but I know
that this ice bath is going to change
everything for the better yeah all right
well on the on that note uh thanks so
much Rick thank you we will both get
some ice I'll let you get out first
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by on it I have used on it products for
years if you look in my kitchen in my
garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it comm forward
slash Tim that's onn IT comm forward
slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
brand check it all out on it comm
forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by 99designs your
one-stop shop for all things graphic
design related I have used 99 designs
for everything from banner ads to book
covers including sketches and mock-ups
that led to the 4-hour body which later
became number one york times number one
Wall Street Journal and the
brainstorming a lot of it took place
with designers from around the world and
here's how it works whether you need a
t-shirt a business card a website and
app thumbnail whatever it might be you
submit that project and designers from
around the world will send you sketches
and mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim
and until next time thank you for
listening
you